Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Heute gibt es eine richtig, richtig leckere Torte.
Die habe ich vor ein paar Tagen ausprobiert und zwar ist das eine Eclair Torte weil der Boden und der Deckel aus Brandteig besteht
und innen drin haben wir richtig knackige und frische Pistazien und eine unfassbar cremige Vanillefüllung.
So, und jetzt fangen wir direkt mal an.
Übrigens: Heute ist der Fastentag, das Video kommt natürlich ein paar Tage später online.
Falls ich verwirrt wirken sollte, kann es daran liegen,
dass wir jetzt schon 17h haben und seit ein paar Stunden nichts gegessen haben.
Aber Fastenbrechen ist heute um 20:30h
also haben wir uns gedacht: Backen wir einfach eine schöne Torte!
So, wir fangen jetzt direkt an mit dem Brandteig.
Dafür gebe ich in meinen Topf einfach Wasser, Butter und eine Prise Salz
und lasse das einmal kurz aufkochen.
Das Ganze jetzt nur einmal kurz aufkochen lassen, dann mit der Hitze runter auf die mittlere Stufe
und jetzt geben wir in einem Schwung das Mehl mit hinzu
und dann müssen wir den Teig abbrennen, deswegen ist es ja auch Brandteig.
Und ich z.B., also ich benutze ja meine Töpfe natürlich.
Die sind aus beschichtetem Material und daher sieht man quasi nicht, wie das abbrennt.
Weil eigentlich bildet sich so eine weiße Haut am Topfboden,
das kennt ihr wenn ihr das schonmal gemacht habt.
Richtet euch einfach daran, dass ihr das 4min lang ständig in Bewegung halten müsst
und dann ist der Brandteig fertig.
Naja fast fertig, da fehlen ja dann noch die Eier.
[Kiki] Seht ihr? Ich sag doch ich bin heute verwirrt!
[Hamza] Nicht nur heute!
Nachdem der Brandteig dann 4min lang abgebrannt wurde, einmal umfüllen.
Ich gebe das direkt in die Schüssel meiner Küchenmaschine
und gebe den Teig auch an den Rändern so ein bisschen nach oben
damit er eben besser und schneller auskühlen kann.
15min habe ich das Ganze stehen lassen und jetzt geht's weiter mit den Eiern.
Ihr könnt sie auch per Hand mit einem Kochlöffel einrühren aber das braucht richtig viel Kraft.
Und daher benutze ich gerne die Maschine und rühre dann die Eier nacheinander ein.
Also immer eins einrühren und wenn es sich verbunden hat, dann das nächste einrühren.
Zwischendurch werdet ihr das Gefühl haben, dass es sich niemals verbindet
und dann dürft ihr nicht verzagen und auf meine Worte hören:
Das wird schon, ihr braucht einfach nur Geduld!
[Hamza] Also ich finde es immer sehr schön, wie du die Tipps hier gibst!
[Kiki] Danke!
[Hamza] Ehrlich! Das ist immer so mit Liebe, man merkt das voll.
[Kiki] Ich will halt, dass es euch gelingt! Ich will nicht, dass ihr verzweifelt seid Zuhause.
[Hamza] Kiki, du bist toll!
So, jetzt ist ein sehr klebriger Brandteig entstanden
und den teilen wir jetzt grob in der Mitte
und verteilen ihn auf 2 Tortenringe mit 22cm Durchmesser.
Ich nehme jetzt auch meine Hände - ich nehme jetzt auch meine Hände!
Ich befeuchte mir jetzt auch die Hände mit etwas Wasser weil der Teig ist wirklich sehr klebrig.
Und dann könnt ihr ihn so vom Löffel entfernen und richtig schön verteilen.
Also es wird auch wirklich sehr flach nur und später geht das noch ein bisschen im Ofen auf.
Und jetzt kommen unsere 2 Brandteige in den vorgeheizten Backofen, das ist super wichtig.
Und zwar auf 200° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und da backe ich sie dann nacheinander für 28min.
Falls ihr einen sehr großen Backofen habt, könnt ihr natürlich auch beide zusammen backen
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder, denn es mit den Pistazien weiter.
Die Pistazien werden jetzt richtig schön in der beschichteten Pfanne angeröstet
und es riecht schon so gut!
Ich werde euch meine Pistazien aus Gaziantep verlinken, die sind jetzt ganz neu.
Falls ihr das vorletzte Video - oder das vorvorletzte Video? Auf jeden Fall hab ich's mal angekündigt.
Falls ihr das verpasst habt, hier nochmal die Info, dass ihr meine Pistazien jetzt auch in meinem Shop bekommt.
Und das Ganze ohne Schale und ungesalzen, perfekt für süße Rezepte.
Und die gerösteten Nüsse gebe ich jetzt hier in meinen Mixer und werde sie ganz grob mixen.
Zu den Pistazien geben wir dann noch Puderzucker und etwas Orangenblütenwasser.
Das Ganze dann kurz miteinander verrühren und fertig ist der Pistazienteil!
Den lasse ich kurz beiseite stehen und zeige euch jetzt die leckere Vanillefüllung.
Dafür habe ich jetzt hier auch die Rührschüssel meiner Küchenmaschine.
Das funktioniert natürlich auch mit 'nem Handrührgerät aber die Creme ist halt wirklich sehr einfach zusammengerührt.
Daher gebe ich jetzt zuallererst Doppelrahmfrischkäse in die Schüssel,
gebe Vanilleextrakt dazu, und reibe dann auch schonmal eine - einen Bio Zitronen..
[Kiki] Jetzt bin ich ausm Konzept!
[Hamza] Man merkt du fastest! Komm, ganz langsam!
[Hamza] Komm, trink 'nen Schluck Wasser, dann geht's wieder!
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Kiki] Also Wasser -
[Hamza] *lacht*
Also, Vanilleextrakt gebt ihr schon zum Doppelrahmfrischkäse
und reibt noch die Schale einer Bio Zitrone hinein.
So, jetzt hab ich's aber!
Den Puderzucker jetzt schon mit dazu sieben
und dann fange ich an, das Ganze schonmal auf niedriger Geschwindigkeit miteinander zu verbinden,
gehe dann immer höher, also drehe das Rad der Geschwindigkeit immer höher
und gebe dann schon mal Sahne mit dazu.
Wichtig ist, dass die Zutaten eiskalt sind also ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank kommen,
dann kann auch nichts mehr schiefgehen.
Während das Ganze aufschlägt, lasse ich dann gleich auch schon Sahnefest einrieseln
dann dauert das so 1½-2min und dann ist die Creme auch schon fertig.
Jetzt ist unsere Creme auch fertig
und das Zusammenspiel zwischen Vanille und dem Zitronenschalenabrieb: ein Traum!
Und jetzt geht es nur noch darum, alles zu schichten.
Ich werde jetzt hier schonmal meine Böden vom Tortenring lösen.
Da fahre ich einmal mit meinem Backformlöser an den Seiten drumherum
weil sonst, wenn ihr das einfach so aufmacht, reißt euch auf einmal der Brandteig
und das wäre doch mega ärgerlich!
Und den Deckel schneide ich jetzt schon in passende Stücke.
[Kiki] Guck mal wie viele Stücke ich mache. Ich denke es werden 12.
[Hamza] Achso, du schneidest schonmal vor!
[Kiki] Ja weißt du, warum ich schonmal vorschneide? Weil die Creme so luftig und leicht ist
[Kiki] und wir dann das nicht runterdrücken wollen, also in die Creme eindrücken möchten.
Die vorgeschnittenen Stücke dann nochmal on top legen,
da könnt ihr auch einfach nochmal mit den Händen dran fummeln damit das auch schön gerade ist.
Und jetzt muss unsere Torte für mindestens 30min in den Kühlschrank, was ja eigentlich gar nicht viel ist.
Also ist das summa summarum eine schnelle Torte!
Und für all diejenigen, die sie jetzt nachmachen möchten
und sagen "Ich möcht's aber gern am Vortag vorbereiten", das ist auch kein Problem!
Denn die Torte hält sich 3 Tage lang im Kühlschrank
und ich gebe am Ende nochmal ordentlich Puderzucker on top für die Deko
und wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Diesmal hab ich's nicht am Anfang erwähnt aber ich hoffe, ihr habt euch falls ihr neu dabei seid nicht gewundert,
wo denn die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen.
Die schreibe ich euch immer unten die Videobeschreibung ganz einfach zum Screenshotten.
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch eine schöne Zeit.
Wenn ihr die Torte ausprobiert habt, dann schreibt mir bitte unbedingt ein Feedback.
Ich find sie unglaublich lecker und freue mich, dass ich sie euch - dass ich sie jetzt mit euch teilen konnte!
Und entschuldigt meine Verhaspler!
Puh! Noch 2h, dann ist das Fastenbrechen und dann habe ich bestimmt auch wieder einen klaren Kopf.
Ansonsten habt noch einen schönen Tag, bis dann!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!